[Music]
this next guest needs no intro she's one
of my heroes she's a legend her name is
margaret cho and we're going to talk
about cats right away i talk about this
all the time i want cats so bad but i
don't understand what they value and
they and i like find myself being so
insecure around them i'm like the dorky
kid in school trying to get the popular
girl to like me i'm just like what do
you need to do like i'm like it's my
hair
like i just get
and you realize like the more you try
with a cat the more repellent your
energy is like they just oh yeah my cats
make me starstruck
that's exactly
it's like every time i'm around a cat i
feel like i'm bombing with a celebrity i
admire i'm like really star struck by
them like because i'm starstruck by your
cats they're so
famous and like i love their work so
much but it's really like i have to be
cool so i feel it's it's kind of like
being like with helen marin and um
dame judy dench and
um anthony hopkins that's who they are
they're they're just like really they're
so amazing my one cat my boy is a fuck
boy
because he'll only come to uh he'll
ignore me all day
and then he'll come to my bed at like
two in the morning and then get on my
chest and then like knead my boobs like
for six hours
so
doing your mammogram yeah he does the
mammogram and then he'll like sleep with
uh he sleeps between my legs and on my
boobs and then won't talk to me all day
ah but then all night in between my legs
all my boobs are the side chick
it's so side chick but he doesn't have
any he doesn't have any other um won't
be with you in public yeah it won't be
so you think
so i don't know who knows what happens
when you leave he's such a fuck boy like
and it's it's fine but it's like really
like i have to just accept it to be the
side chick if you try harder it's just
going to get worse it's just really sad
so i'm just like in i'm i'm fine with it
but he is so sweet
i'm also fascinated by cats because
every time i go to you know i've had a
lot of family members in hospitals and
stuff and doctors even they're like yeah
we use cats to find out who has cancer
yeah like in nursing homes and stuff
like that like a cat will go in they're
like oh we should probably scan this
person yeah like cats can smell cancer
like what kind of alien
yeah they're just species they're so
incredible i've spent a lot of time
listening to you on podcasts talking
about cats and dogs so
i try on this podcast to never ask the
guests things that they've been asked
too much on other podcasts okay so i
know this is gonna break your heart but
i'm not gonna ask you how you got into
comedy if that's okay
i have a feeling you've answered that
okay every right yeah we're gonna go to
like wild places yeah um i just want to
say really quick i you have been a hero
of mine first
in a big way and i'm definitely nervous
and this is very surreal for me so thank
you for doing this thank you
i don't talk about sex on this podcast
very much i don't know why because i
think most people think that's like my
thing
but i wanted to talk to you about
is it true that you were dominatrix at
one point in your life yeah i'm like not
a good one though like i um like can i
whip you yeah yeah i'm like i'm like so
about like
asking permission but also i'm like kind
of lazy and you know when you're a
dominatrix you have to be able to
get into their head and
know how to push their boundaries and
you know you've got to be like a good
one like it's
it's worth all the money that people pay
them i have a friend that does this as
well and she was like i'm sure
to me i'm always just fascinated by like
human nature and when sex is sexual and
when it's not and
you know what our sort of
needs behind closed doors mean about us
and i feel like lately i've been dealing
with a little bit of shame with wanting
very aggressive a very aggressive man
and there is this shame of like oh i'm
like not a good woman if i want to be
choked or i'm not a good woman if i want
a man to like
boss me around or whatever but i think
there's just something interesting going
on right now where a lot of women i know
are like is it okay to like
have these fantasies where i'm getting
choked and what you know it's just like
in it i'm just curious like what you've
learned about like human nature and
what
invisible wounds yield what kind of
sexual needs you know well i think what
it is is that when you're really good at
work and you're really good at life you
want somebody to
be able to come in and um
be able to override that sexually so
when you're submissive sexually
generally what it means is that you're
powerful in your daily life so that's
why most ceos want to get peed on that's
why trump wants to get peed on all the
time not that he's good at anything
but he's gonna get peanuts he wants to
get peed on he has like talked a lot
about it like he's very into getting
peed on where on like where like on the
like where do
i mean i i would think that he wants to
get peed
on his face that seems to be what i've
got garnered from all the years of
hearing about him juaniquepito
but um that's why like like people who
are powerful
generally
want to be dominated and
i mean it's just as true for women as as
it is for men i think even more so with
women because there's so
fewer women who are very powerful
in their lives it's so weird to think of
like all the ceos and people we look up
to just getting peed off they all want
to get peed on they lean in they all
want to get um
trampled on they all want to be stepped
on their step on their head step on
their face my friend that does this um
uh
uh they what she does is she has to find
him in like at work like in the lobby
like push him into the bathroom and like
humiliate him like he wants to be like
humiliated yeah like you're a piece of
shit like you're disgusting you have a
small dick it's like that kind of stuff
and i'm like is that a
is that a primary caretaker thing is
that a mommy thing is that a
no it what it is is that it's
eroticizing the um
imposter syndrome that they have
so
in
general also people who are very
successful in their work and in their
life have a measure of imposter syndrome
so to kind of metabolize that they want
to eroticize it so that's part of it um
when you eroticize um something then it
gives you a kind of ownership over
mentally and so that's kind of the
the uh what this sort of skeletal
nature of what that is
and then there's all the other stuff on
top of it whether that's mommy issues
whether that's um kind of an upbringing
thing whether that's just something that
you saw when you were in your formative
year sexually that
made you really like take notice right
in general that's kind of what is erotic
and what is um
going to be perceived that way for the
rest of their lives you know for your
rest your sexual life
also as she's saying all this yes she is
holding a bull dick
him gesturing like it's a
a pointer
you should do doggy dominatrix dog and
nature excuse me
tricks there is a human dog park in um
i'm sorry san francisco of course there
is there's like where you can go with
your puppy or your uh
i think you bring human cats too there's
a lot of human cats and human dogs or
human kittens human dogs which is not
like furries it's like because furries
is a whole nother um
arena of
more identity so you have more stuff to
wear right right right but you can
conceal your face kind of thing yeah
they have a lot of um
they have a lot of like uh things that
where they they create their character
so it's not so straightforward like an
animal from the wild it can be a
mythological
yeah mythological creature or a creature
they sort of like made a hybrid like a
mashup of different kinds of anime
animals or animation characters you know
what i didn't know is that i mean i
learned it very quickly when i did a
like a segment for like a tonight show
or something um
the renaissance fair
at night it's a total fuck fest yeah
they like do molly and yes pirates fuck
each other yeah with the turkey leg
yeah it's hugely um
it's connected to uh
sort of bdsm communities it's connected
to any kind of larping communities or
cosplay too
there's a sort of a link
um same kind of dna there but yeah
totally obsessed and then i'm also have
to say this out loud the pee on the face
is making me think my vagina is weird
because i if i want to pee on someone's
face my pee goes all over the it doesn't
go yeah mine goes to my space and then i
always fart
when you pee yeah like part usually
yeah if i'm prep like usually if i have
to pee on somebody i'm pressing down
because i like don't want to yeah
and then i'm like pushing down really
hard also i don't drink enough water so
i'm like pushing down really hard and
i'm dehydrated and then i fart and it's
like such a bummer
that is such a bummer but i i don't like
i don't like p play i only like p play
if he play
if it's in the shower so i the one time
i uh this guy that i um was dating we
had the most fun sex because we made
jokes like i had never been in a
relationship where sexually you could
like laugh and if you queefed you would
just start laughing instead of being
embarrassed it was like an older guy
and you know he had been married he had
had a kid so he had seen his ex-wife had
a fist just like he'd seen women's
bodies and nothing was gross to him and
that's like a really fun person to be
with yeah where you never have to feel
embarrassed or whatever but he would um
uh uh like one time i told him um we
were like laughing one day uh and i was
like okay one day in bed i want you to
call me a pig but don't tell like don't
tell me when just like surprise me
and like we're like kind of drinking
that like six months later we're like
having sex doggy style he was like dang
it you
big we
laughed for like
four hours like we were dying like we
had like a very funny sex life and then
one time we were like kind of tipsy we
were in the in the shower and i was like
he'd always talked about we're like he's
like i'm gonna pee on you at some point
and i was like not in my house not in my
it just it's a lot of prep
there's a lot you have to put down a
tarp you have to go to home depot it's
like a whole thing it's a whole thing
it's like i don't want to squirt like
i'm sure it's lovely but i don't i i
like
the cleanup just seems like a lot
and um and then uh so he he peed on me
in the show i was like we're doing the
shower and like peed like on my face in
the shower and i couldn't i was just
like i couldn't do it i couldn't be
serious like it was just too funny it's
so funny it's funny and it's like a
childish sort of like guys all peonies
it's so silly and like it's just um
it's something they're very very sort of
natural about it like it's just like
it's a ridiculous thing
so so ridiculous like i feel like the
older i get the more i'm like this is so
ridiculous like why have you ever felt
insecure about this why like yeah i
think it's weird though too like um
when you're uh the female comic too
because
if you have sex with men
men have such an idea of like women in
comedy and like they're so afraid of us
too so there's something weird about it
like they feel like they can't
relax well that's interesting because a
lot of guys think like are you gonna
make fun of me are you gonna say this
and yeah like that's the biggest red
flag to me if you guys like are you
gonna yeah that's weird bye
and then you know it's like if they're
gonna say that then you want to
be like do something funny or
interesting or mildly entertaining like
it's like when someone comes up to you
or or like a family member tells you the
most boring story for 20 minutes and
it's like
you can have that
you're like thanks
you know what i'm gonna use your boring
ass dmv story as my closer thank you so
much for that jewel
um
um that's fascinating to me curious if
this is an ongoing conversation in the
podcast about do you have any inkling of
what a foot fetish like what the genesis
is i think there's a couple going
theories one is that it looks like
little dicks right um that's the freud
one even the freud seems like he's
everything's been debunked that he's
postulated and then um the other is
called cathexis at least the other one
that i know where when babies crawl
towards their moms and a lot of moms
like if they're like barefoot and they
crawl and their genitals are rubbing
against the carpet and they're looking
at their mom's feet
they associate pleasure with feet and
that becomes like a fetish yeah i i
think it has something to do with um
just like the the
feet are the sort of entry point to the
vagina so it's like if you split the
feet then they're like the vagina is
right there so if the vagina is too
unapproachable like a vagina is so
threatening they'll start with the feet
and then move their way up but then they
get stuck on feet i think it's it's a
dry vagina too maybe you're just into
dry vagina maybe or you're just afraid
this
the middle that's what they fuck right
if your feet are together yeah they want
to do like a foot job where you have
your feet like in a prayer position so
if you can put you do your like
butterflies and then you can do up like
that but that actually gives me a
charlie horse i was gonna say that i'm
not stuck i actually really harshly
that's why i have so much sciatic nerve
damage
i did too
that but it's a very um it's probably
good for your core yeah
to get your feet in that position your
spirit by your core
it's um a foot job is usually they just
want to like
lick your feet or do like foot worship
which is that's fine i just um
i'm not aroused by foot anything i'm
actually quite ticklish
me too yeah what's the last thing that
surprised you astonished you left you
aghast um
oh gosh
uh
what is i know what's mine what is
surprising
i mean the will smith thing
that that was shocking that it's i was
like oh my god like i was yelling to the
sky i was like walking around like
huh like i was
speechless i was a guest yeah i was that
that was being the show video too that
was shocking yeah yeah but then after
but after
seeing the um will smith thing that that
was more shocking just because it was
just after that it was something like it
seemed like anything was possible yeah
that was really shocking because it was
live television and then he won
and then he was crying and then it was
like really like
and i i did a movie with will smith and
um i blew my take
more than i've ever blown it because i
don't know what was going on but they
were doing uh my coverage and he still
had to be in every single one because
and i he wanted to do his off-camera
coverage yeah well it was um yeah he had
he just did he just does his off-camera
coverage and i wish that he didn't
because i blew that take you know eddie
murphy has something 56 i can do it so
does bruce willis
yeah usually
usually
usually they're if you're like working
with the big star like that they'll have
some it's just like a tennis ball on a
stick yeah which is fine for me but i i
blew my take so many and he didn't slap
me one time not even i could i should
have gotten slapped for as many times i
blew that dick it was so bad it was so
bad
were you nervous or you just no um it
was a speech
and i had not got they had was one of
those things where they didn't send out
the script
and they just never said it
and i just never looked to see if he
should have just held the lines for you
it was like really can you just staple
these lines to your chest it was a
really long script
i mean it's never to cut back to him
like so hard to say it was like all
these long words i didn't know what they
meant
it was so funny because
i just like didn't know and uh he never
he he was not mad i would have been so
mad but i was he was cool about it he
was fine i i mean to me that in that
experience it seemed like he was the
most patient
person ever
before he snapped yeah and it was a it
was a stressful day too because uh trump
had just won
and hillary had given her concession
speech and then we went on to say what
was this movie it's called bright oh
yeah yeah and uh it's um
i do a really little pardon it but it
was like such a weird thing where like i
never got the script and i don't know
what happened i don't know why i didn't
get it
and i just flubbed so many lines and i
just couldn't say all the things and he
was so patient so it's the worst it was
so bad that's the probably the last time
i was actually embarrassed about
something oh interesting and i don't
really get embarrassed me that is really
interesting i mean especially like just
go away just i'm also big on going like
hey can you not look can you just can
someone like i'm
finally at a place where i can and june
rayfield taught me this of like being
able to claim your space and knowing
what you need to thrive if i can
identify like this kind of just happened
for the first time when i was shooting
something where i was going oh hey is
there any way
i could have this person like on this
side of the camera like i didn't ever
want to come off like a bitch or like i
was you know couldn't do anything but to
be able to go like oh hey this is
distracting me i don't have to feel bad
about it i everyone wants me to do my
best work so i'm gonna risk just being a
bitch and saying do you mind if you just
like can i put the lines on this
computer like i know them or i've
studied them but i'm just telling you
i'm gonna can i just put them here like
just being able to ask for that yeah
it's great it's been yes it's taken me
so long to be able to do that it's hard
it's really hard because then once
you've once i fucked something up twice
it's oh it's over like i'm in a loop and
then i keep fucking it up yeah i have to
it has to be perfect like or else i'm
just gonna keep fucking it up yeah and
it's like the perfectionism leads to
procrastination leads to pro i get
paralyzed yeah and i'm in a shit so i'm
like we need to just take five minutes i
need to go listen to music and like come
back and will smith can't be here
i really would rather just read with the
like grip please it's so uh yeah it's so
hard but i yeah that was the last time i
was shocked was when he slapped
chris and then but i was like this is a
joke like i didn't believe it at first
like this is this is some kind of a
there was something about it that seemed
so cool because it was the way that he
to me
it was he had so many opportunities to
change his mind he had so many
opportunities i mean it was like 12
steps one two on the third or fourth
step he could have been like you know
what i'm gonna turn this into a noogie
or i'm gonna turn this into a fake punch
like he could have been like yeah
he's like a great actor he could have
acted like he was you know he could have
course corrected and that's the moment
also i was like oh this is the value
program like every year in program you
get another second to pause like the
idea that you can like at any moment or
soon within having a reactionary uh uh
self-sabotaging negative investment in
your future self moment you can make a
choice just you know yeah at any moment
you can hang up the phone or stop
texting or
leave
the situation but it was like 12. it was
so much time yeah
yeah and it was also such a bro like i
mean it doesn't get me in trouble but um
i everyone's like what would you have
done if chris rock if you were chris
rock in that situation i'm always like
if he hit me like that
on stage i'd be like oh well well this
is not how i thought you were gonna come
out as gay but here we are
it was just such a like broadway like
slap it was very easy to uh photoshop it
in into like mommy dearest like it was
such a very theatrical it was so
theatrical so very but it it was really
um
it just looked like a sketch to me so
much that i couldn't believe that there
wasn't a sketch that it was really
strange it was it was yeah it was just
too surreal to believe it's a big setup
i'm like this is a set up to something
this is set up to something i think also
the look on chris's face was so
heartbreaking because he didn't
anticipate and like he he this guy is
storming up to him and he's like what
are you doing man like yeah wouldn't
have occurred to him in a million years
yeah whereas maybe if it was a white guy
i'd be like what are you doing dude like
he was like hey man like it was just so
devastating in that moment that that if
it was a sketch or something i'm like he
would be like like there'd have to be
some kind of concept of like knowing
this was coming and he's just like even
up to the last second yeah it would
never occur to him that something that
wild would happen it was so shocking and
i think that's probably yeah the last
time i was really really shocked but
then the chappelle thing that happened
after to me was like really like
well this is
it it was almost like it was it deadened
the effect yeah because now you're like
oh well anything could happen well it's
interesting also because the thing that
i hear a lot um especially from like
people not in you know this business
that are like how can why didn't they
kick them out right away like why are
they and it's like you know i think
people forget like i'm making a
generalization but this business is a
bunch of like
insecure traumatized people that just
want to be liked and and we
tend to minimize or forget about the
freeze response i mean imagine someone
in that room being like him out like
there's it's a room full of people who's
like
artists like inner child running the
show
are all people that left their town
because they wanted to be loved by
strangers you know that who knows what
went on in their childhood to make them
have that bottomless pit of need for
love yeah in a situation where two
authority figures were fighting you know
and it's like mommy and daddy are
fighting in that freeze response you
know to see everyone in that freeze
response i was like oh yeah this is why
harvey weinstein happened this is why
kevin space like like
this is not a group of people
you know who
are why in general are wired to stand up
to an authority figure
right right and we don't know how i mean
and and it's just too
fast to process like it was too and it
was all televised and the same thing
it's just too it was really traumatic i
think for a lot of people and i think it
was also just like a great lesson to go
like this is how horrible things
persist
you know is that when the people freeze
i mean just watching the way that no one
really could do anything yeah and and i
was like yeah it's like
it's like it was a scary side of human
nature to see yeah people go into
paralysis just like like i would have
disassociated yeah and like to me it's
like when you become an artist i'm not
saying everyone has some kind of trauma
or everyone has had to disassociate in
some way i don't think we
sign up to become other people because
we love hanging out in our own heads
like that is very much a form of
disassociation for me so just watching
everyone just like disassociate and it's
like
you know be whatever like whatever their
trauma was see just seeing that happen
was just like really
wild
yeah um so i also um i'm jumping around
i know but i've been you know
studying you for years being a fan of
yours for years but i recently was so
blown away by a conversation and humbled
and made and jealous of uh and learned
from you i was listening to you on maybe
it was ben folds podcast
um which was
awesome and um
you were talking about tick tock and you
were just like yeah it's a great way to
like have like a quick premise or
something that's 30 and i was like how
are you not furious about like like
every comedian and i hear like fuck dude
fuck this new like
everyone's so resistant to change
because we've spent so long trying to
master a certain
format or a certain amount of time and
all of a sudden you're able to do an
hour and now i have to do 30 minutes 20
minutes i have to compete with these
kids dancing like you have this um
openness for change and this
this um
not surrender but like this sort of like
oh yeah comedy's going this direction
now and it's like you don't get
defensive and i mean you're a legend and
you've been doing this so long obviously
but i i there are so many people like
fuck this that's not common and i was
like that's how we should be we should
be like go ride the horse in the
direction it's going i think so i mean i
don't know i watched your tick tock um
wait was esther monster it was so cute
okay and she's like it's you you're
doing all your hot girl stuff and it was
so funny and it was a perfect way to
approach
that kind of like thing of like just
it i think that it's really um it's just
doing fun things like tick-tock to me is
really fun because it's just like we
don't know what it is but it's really
engaging and it's it's just like such a
momentary look into somebody's life and
so there's there's all sorts of
different sort of ideas about how you go
viral i mean i'm not interested in that
i just like want to participate in the
culture of it yeah and i just like for
me i was like like you know i think that
i you know
get very resentful and it's my ego and
it's not emotionally sober when i go
like no like i can do an hour like
that's comedy like and then i'm sort of
because i'm
in the core of it is i'm afraid of being
embarrassed
you know i'm afraid of being bad at
something i'm afraid of looking stupid
you know which is um the main thing
about me and tik tok right now and i had
someone like i had some like help me
like and i'm like i don't need someone i
know how to do this like i just have to
trust my gut and go like what am i good
at i don't have to do i don't have to do
lazy cheerleading i don't have to do
dancing i don't have to do what everyone
else is doing just do what i think is
funny for 30 seconds or a minute or
whatever and i don't have to compete
with anyone but it's been really
watching you
be that sort of fluid about it like
like i mean i guess like you've seen
like how
social media and the internet have like
help comedy whereas i'm always like uh
anyone can get famous now on tick-tock
and i worked so hard and this person
just did a dance and they're selling out
the chicago theater like i like
my ego like gets involved which is just
so self-defeating no i mean it's it's um
i understand it's it's hard though
because
people are like going to
watch you because they love you and they
want to see you talk about why you don't
use a vibrator which to me that's the
the most
self-defeating part you don't use a
vibrator that's what i found out on
tick-tock that is so
funny
emily got sent three vibrators and we
like screamed and ran away from them i
would love to i'm just i truly am not
taking on a new charging port
i'm not taking on a new thing
like i actually tried after we had
chelsea lynn on the podcast because
she's the queen of vibrators we're
showing that i was like i'm gonna use it
somewhere i couldn't find the charger
and i was like i'm done if i never have
an orgasm again i'm not putting
it will dry up my pussy to charge it and
plug it in
but i will i'm gonna try
i have one that you can ride like a
horse
that you actually uh a lot of a lot of
what horse girls
what happens with horse girls this was
not the case for me
but a lot of girls and when they're you
know
13 14 15 and they're riding horses they
have orgasms from riding horses yeah
they break their hymen on you know yeah
that's a big sort of horse girl if a
girl is like
doing two extra jumps and won't get off
the horse you know yeah
yeah that's but this is a good one
because like a sybian type thing it's a
sybian and there's no it's not a
charging you have to actually plug it in
it's not a sabian it's some small like
an old school like one of those horses
outside of a like grocery store
you put it in a diet yeah
no it's um i think it's called the motor
bunny and then you it's a small it's
like a sybian it's the same sensation as
sabian but it's smaller the motor bunny
i just you know what it is i think i
for the longest time
sex toys were like
the the people i dated would do whatever
what like i always never want to
emasculate anyone or embarrass anyone by
having one and now i'm over that shit so
now's the perfect time the ones i see
though sometimes i don't even know how
they that one that's like the double
claw
oh yeah i i thought it went in your butt
in vagina but it goes in your vagina and
then on top like i just need yeah it's
kind of yeah it's like that or you can
you there's ones that are like you can
use it when you're having vaginal sex
with with somebody else yeah so
and then there's the the i i like sort
of the um the field though which i don't
know if they are around anymore but
they're like a double-ended dildo but
they have um
vibration capability on both sides i'm
gonna say something crazy i'm just gonna
go for it emily close your ears pat
close your ears call hr
uh a person in my life in the last
couple of years that i'm sleeping with
is uh various uh tush plugs
and i'm super game
yeah yeah i'm not eating your ass
because i break out on my chin
so not eating what is it is it because
of the the hair it's just like it's gets
swampy i mean eating it i used to like i
just don't your spit has so much
bacteria but
i don't i can't i have so much from
wearing the mask i already have so much
fucking acne on my chin i can't i can't
have any more cystic zits um
that's my main yeah okay eat your own
ass finger your own ass whatever you
need to do suction it put a whatever but
um i just i it not now
maybe later
when you know we're in the bunker during
the apocalypse and we've run out of shit
to do but like um
but butler
they actually i thought they were more
for the guy
no no no they're great great
yeah they're really and they make me
feel like i don't have a giant pussy
well they tighten your vagina from the
inside also they are act as a second
almost a second g-spot if you if you can
sort of like imagine that there's a
there's an anal spot and they can't have
sex with your butt because something's
in there mm-hmm
yeah you guys just know like
i had ravioli like it just
it's it's to me i was like this just
plugs
possible poof
yeah and makes it so i know like that's
not happening tonight but it's um
there's something about uh when you can
have an orgasm and press on something
anally that is very um
it is like it it's almost like jumping
off point to another organization it's
like so intense yeah and i had never
experienced that before because i i yeah
it's it's
kind of mind-blowing if i'm gonna be
honest yeah plugs are good plugs are i
think i think they're underrated
i think so too i think it's like yeah
there's this i love talking to you
because there's just the way that you
talk about things with just an absence
of taboo and i hope um uh tell me if i'm
i'm going too far off uh you know you've
inspired me to talk about my
sexual abuse
and i'm curious if
what you know first i was just like
writing about it because i was trying so
hard to be of service and like share
with people because you know as you say
like the silent our silence is what
keeps them free yeah and you know and so
i was like and when i heard about other
people's stuff i was like oh it's not
just me it's not just my fault that's
not just my secret and i'm not just like
bad and gross and just this like um
piece of garbage that someone knew they
could do this to me and no one would
ever find out or care because i'm so
that useless or whatever and um and i'm
curious if there was a little bit of a
uh amount of uh
a delinea a period where you
were torn about that it was a challenge
like whenever you know like i would try
to talk about it in my comedy people
would the audience would really freeze
up
and it was really hard to get past that
and it was like trying to figure out how
do i crack the code of actually trying
to make people sort of free enough to
understand this is going to a place of
like it's actually going to be good to
talk and i'm okay and this is actually
how i'm going to heal yeah don't worry
about me and it's yeah it's better to
just talk about it but it's also such a
common experience that's happened to so
many people that it's like then you
realize how much
we have to talk about it yeah you know
and um the healing there is
really predicated on how um
much we can be open about it and share
that i think i think it's like that uh
slumber party game light is a feather
stiff as a board yeah yeah if
everybody's trying to lift the burden it
becomes very light yeah
so um but it's hard people get really
freaked out
you know well they're like don't make me
face don't make me think about what i've
been through don't make me think about
you being in pain like it's like a
little bit of uh
you know um
it's not confrontational but it is
interesting when you're like this didn't
happen you would happen to me why are
you uncomfortable people are scared
because they also when they're coming to
see us they need us to
be powerful like we need like a female
comics to win all the time and they
don't want to see us be anything less
than heroic but we can't be we have to
be humble about it we can't speak brag
and we can't
be proud of ourselves and we can't think
we're good but we still have to win we
still have to win but we have to win to
get first place i don't deserve that you
can have it
hello oh hey girl
um
i need to talk to you guys about health
look at this if you're not watching this
is
these are all the pills that i am now
taking doesn't even seem weird to me my
only issue between all these pills is
that i am balding
and i
do think it needs to be addressed
because i have started spraying like
root hairspray around where you can just
sort of see my scalp just the problem is
that the spray brown stuff sometimes it
does trickle down and i look like i'm in
blackface and the point is that 30
million we're trying not to do that
anymore
no that's not funny anymore
30 million women are impacted by
weakened or thinning hair if you are
among them you know that you are not
alone and there's a solution that you
can trust to deliver results now
neutrophil this is the number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement clinically shown to improve
your hair growth thickness and visible
scalp coverage the only downside is that
my pubes micro bag which is a bummer
neutral supports you can't have any of
your hair's too healthy i'm going to
take one of those neutral supplements
healthy hair growth from within by
targeting the five root causes of
thinning hair emily noonan
straight twice
aka stress hormones
environment nutrition and metabolism
through whole body health neutrophil has
three unique formulas to support women
throughout all stages of life including
postpartum and menopause each formula is
physician formulated using uh natural
drug-free medical grade ingredients
excuse me inconsistently effective
dosages so that you will get the most
reliable results in a clinical study 86
of women reported improved hair growth
after six
months while the technology is here go
for it em over three thousand top
doctors and stylists recommend neutral
as an effective and high quality
solution for healthier hair you can grow
thicker healthier hair and support our
show by going to nutrafold.com and
entering the promo code gfy to save 15
on your first month's subscription this
is their best offer anywhere and it is
available only to us customers for a
limited time plus free shipping on every
order get 15 off at neutraful.com
spelled n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l-dot-com
promo code g-f-y look at me who am i
say i'm gonna grow your hair i'm gonna
make your hair grow out
do want healthy hair beautiful silky
locks
just give me 400 million dollars cash
via western union
promo code gfy
my dog's wolf
sorry i am actually taking this pill all
right so i'm still doing stand-up um
emily heard some of my new banger
premises this morning she said we're
workshops she was pretty thrilled about
it because i've already started writing
new materials so this will all be new
material june 24th in calgary alberta
prince island's park you guys if we
don't sell this out david spade is going
to blow his brains out like all of his
friends in the 90s um
i don't even know who i'm referring to
really i do
i feel like that well no one did it on
purpose isn't he shot by his own wife
yeah it was a lot of accidental yeah
yeah yeah june 26th i'm gonna be back in
toronto ontario i just shot a tv show
there i will be very excited to be going
back uh it's sold out but i'm sure some
people are gonna be wimps and get
confused about the masks and um
be like wait that's not joan rivers but
i'll see you at danforth music hall july
1st west hampton beach new york i am
i'm kind of nervous about performing in
west hampton beach is it going to just
be like a bunch of billionaire like it's
gonna be like everyone in tory burch and
like salmon pants like who is gonna be i
mean it's july fourth weekend so that's
a big one come early are there gonna be
any normal people there that aren't like
from succession yeah because the bunch
of new yorkers like young new yorkers
rent like houses out there and do summer
friday weekends there and the problem i
talk too much shit so for me i know
what'll happen is i'll be like talking
shit and like making fun of someone some
guy's boat shoes and his salmon chinos
and these little shirts with little
snails on them you know like no it's
going to be there it's going to be like
oh remember when we did that corporate
event yes yes we did the corporate event
it's going to be that group it's going
to be a lot of vests i'm going to like
roast someone in a patagonia vest
because i go oh patagonia vest i have
one of those we're the same we're not
the same yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah cause
it's you get to wear that to work yeah
uh and it's gonna be like the head of
cbs or something right
which is really where i want this
podcast to start airing that would
really burn a bridge for me that would
break my heart because that is i believe
that's the end goal which by the way
random i i don't know if i'm a long time
i've started writing the pilot for good
for you tv show
good because emmy's looking at
apartments right now
your name is emily but i'm glad you're
thinking emmy good good
i already know who i'm not thinking it's
actually right now i'm keeping a list my
whole career the open is actually pretty
good like the open is um
uh
the open is well there's like a cold
open but then it's me uh sitting down
like okay i'm gonna start a podcast like
um so i'm gonna ask all my guy friends
that are already in the podcast space
like likes for advice yeah yeah you know
and it's just like getting cuts like
bobby leaving okay like look here all
you gotta do is just like you know be
yourself
right you know talk about fucking
hookers and they're like what like i
don't know how to do this and then i go
to like you know uh rogan or something
so yeah just like talk about like yeah
just be yourself i'm like have you seen
my youtube comments no one wants that
that's really funny just like cutting to
all of the a mash-up of like all the
guys giving me advice just like i won't
be on page one but it's like what is
every
man's nightmare like listening to a
woman complain that he loves imagine
signing up to listen to a woman
complaining that you haven't do not get
to fuck at any point like we don't know
that are you guys sure this is like a
business
like it's very unclear to me september
8th cincinnati ohio i'll be at the taft
theater uh september 9th philadelphia
pennsylvania miriam theater uh very
excited for that i'm gonna actually
spend some time over there um and stay
for a while and then go to uh richmond
virginia on the 10th at the national
theater september 24th i'll be in
charles charlotte's view
charlottesville
charlotte's charlottesville virginia
i'm going to charlottesville virginia
paramount
the paramount theater
back
to the show
i am curious because i'm so um i've been
in a 12-step program for quite a while
and um uh i was reading so much or
listening to your podcast and just the
way you're able to talk about you know
recovery in such an eloquent way and a
lot of the questions that came in for
you were just about recovery and i'm
coming from like a little bit of a
different angle in terms of emotional
sobriety and i wanted to share a couple
things that i've been struggling with
this week one is that i realized
yesterday so i'm an al-anon and aca
um i did get stopped taking edibles that
was something that was making my life
unmanageable um and so that was not a
match for me i love weed love smoking
weed the edibles just i've talked about
it before strong they're strong and then
in you know program a n a o a whatever
it is the way that it really helps me to
understand is how it's just i have an
allergy so when people go like i have an
allergy to alcohol i have three glasses
of whiskey and i cannot i'll keep
drinking till two in the morning and
then i'll leave my car and i'll give up
my baby it's an allergy so for me
the edibles i just think of it as an
allergy i just have
my because my brain i get so impatient
no judgments doesn't matter doesn't even
need to be a story it's just i take one
and then it takes like 30 40 minutes to
kick in my brain goes it i got a dud
yeah my brain just decides you got a dud
it tells me a story the beast comes
alive and goes that one didn't work in
the in the oven it distributed weird
it's such a specific lie yeah it didn't
work you just wasted that 40 minutes
waiting to get high when you could have
been working you know my workaholism of
course then will come up and then it's
like so go have another one i'll be like
well what if the other ones are done so
let me just take three and just
and i'm like on the 405 going to
7-eleven it's just like i'm just like
firing people that don't work for me i'm
just like calling x's i'm just like so
taking like weird selfies and posting
them like just but hey guys like bad and
so
um but uh in al-anon you know you don't
have to tell you an aca the drugs are
perfectionism control yeah mothering
martyring micromanaging people
other addicts um uh perfection i think i
already said that um and i realized this
past week i had relapsed in an area that
was a really big part of one of my
primary addictions was you know in order
for people to to get their love i have
to be uh productive to them or useful to
them like i really i didn't know for a
long time how to be in a relationship
with someone without
um being useful to them productive in
some way like um rescuing them fixing
them providing for them giving i
realized in the last couple days i
relapsed in like letting people use me
like i've been getting used
and it's this weird thing because my
brain turns it into i'm being of service
like sometimes when your program
justifies your relapse
yeah yeah and i'm like how did my
fucking brain just turn a sick behavior
into
it's like the idea of like i gotta take
a xanax before the n a meeting so that
i'm focused
i mean like that's what i did my brain
was like you're being of service so loan
this person this money or give like i
just was like i'm letting myself be used
and
i i'm just curious you know i look at
the pandemic and i think there's a lot
of things that i just still haven't like
gotten back to the emotional sobriety
because the pandemic was like all the
rules are out the fucking window yeah
and i started isolating and i i had
every excuse in the world
to do the edibles to isolate and then
yeah everyone's got coveted in this so
it's like oh i'm going to be of service
i need to bring this person groceries
they have covet i'm going to do this for
the sprint like it was just like all
bets were off and i'm kind of trying to
get back to being emotionally sober
that's hard after the pandemic emotional
sobriety
to me is the hardest i'm definitely not
that i i want to be but that's like a
that's on another level of like serene
and they call those like people who that
have like the black belt right eleanon's
they can really the graduate program
yeah they have like um their bottle of
water and like a holster you know
they're at the meetings they're shaking
up a salad you're like what the fuck
they have like a nutrigrain bar you're
like what's happening and they're so
like together
and i and sometimes that's
that's another one yeah that's a whole
lot you know sometimes it's too far when
you're like you know using the tide pen
on your stain and the meat like that's
so rigid yes exactly it's so potent yeah
i can't i can't i can't figure any of
that out like i i love the idea of
trying to be sober that way but i have
enough trouble just trying not to drink
alcohol and do drugs
that to me is so fascinating because
when listening to you talk i'm like i
mean it's self-diagnosed um
i mean i'm an alien i can you're
emotionally sober trust me um this is
what we do we we're the judge jury
executioner we decide um the superiority
thing uh and i found that too like i
think living online
for that you know year and a half i
found myself getting really
judgy and really
um you know and another thing that i've
been um relapsing on is gossip
that's a big allen on aca thing is
gossip yeah and
it's hard because a lot of people are
you know the way people behave on social
media and everyone's getting you know
not everyone but with that people
getting canceled i'm finding myself like
you know like voraciously reading these
people that are getting cancelled that
did something toxic and what do they do
and texting about like i just it's like
a drug in my vein and i'm like i am
doing this to avoid looking at myself i
am high on self-righteous indignation i
am doing this so that i don't have to
look at myself i am looking at people
that are huge pieces of shit
to feel superior superior in comparison
to someone who's a piece of garbage like
if i need that to feel good about myself
i really need to look at
doing more esteemable actions to build
my self-esteem and with the pandemic
like i have not been being of service to
people i have not been volunteering i
have not been like
outreach like i just am like
i i was just thinking about this the
other day and i was listening to you on
podcast and i was like i want
that like i want to think like that
mm-hmm
it's hard though too because it's kind
of like
when am i uh
turning these bad things over and when
am i in denial like it's like how do we
know
how do we know any sort of the right way
to live it's just like but there's also
a way to live that you're
content and you feel good
so it's hard it's hard to know like
what's being of service and what's
getting used that's to me is a very fine
line or trying to get someone to owe you
you know or going like yeah i'll drive
you to the airport and then keeping
score
and then going well if i drive in the
airport then he's going to like me or
she's going to like me or this she's
going to tell people that i'm a nice
person or i'm doing it out of obligation
because i don't have boundaries or
self-respect and i want to
subconsciously create chaos
you know hard it's hard so that i'm get
the adrenaline of the chaos and the
and then the dopamine that the
adrenaline turns into the internal drug
cabinet of like oh i just got my fix
because i did something and now the
story is
well i drove him to the airport and he
didn't even show up at my birthday and
now i get to be a victim
yeah and these are all the ways that we
just avoid intimacy and real human
connection you know these are all the
ways of like be i'm a bean counter so i
definitely am like okay you did this so
i get to do this or i did this and so
you have to do this because of that and
you know it's like
that's not the way to have a
relationship
um i think it's it's just weird like all
that stuff like that we do in our head
it's just a way to avoid the truth of
who we really are
but the work that i've done i think
for me i realize i actually have come
out the other side
and i i think i think i'm actually
asexual
by the way i get that's so weird that
you said that weird but i that is wild
because i was talking to someone the
other day who i believe was a little bit
transphobic and um someone in my life
who just was not
you know i'm trying to find patients a
family member who's you know not
who was like i don't get they them thing
or whatever and i was trying to just
patiently
explain
lgbtqia and saying asexual is a part of
this too because and sorry to be
circuitous about this but
i'm really um
pissed uh these days about whatever this
thing going on about drag queens and
kids and it's just it makes me so
fucking mad because um
you know i was raised uh my mom worked
in a department store you know my whole
life and i was basically raised by gay
men and gay couples you know they worked
in the neiman marcus they worked in
bloomingdale's they did the windows they
came over did our christmas trees and
like like i don't when i think
gay men are i don't think about sex like
i just it doesn't like why are you doing
why did you bring that into it like it's
just so you know the gay men that raised
me and that i spent all my holidays with
and all my after school days with like
they were my respite from feeling
sexualized like they it was the straight
men that were creepy with yeah you know
so to me and then i don't know just
ingest it's like if you know drag queens
you know
the last have you seen a dr it's so ac
it's she's she's on four pairs of spanx
she's not gonna fuck your kid
it would take 40 minutes to get all that
shit off she's gonna know that your
shitty kid touched the wig like there's
no sex happening not at all
levels of caulk and grout and like
makeup and i can't even hug a drag queen
they won't let you within five feet of
that yeah so it's also just drives me
nuts but and i was explaining the
asexual thing and i was like think about
i was like
i go through very asexual
um
periods even when i'm in a relationship
and
that's so interesting because i was
thinking about that the other day and i
was like i usually because we've talked
about i went to
a bunch of sla meetings and um the
sexual anorexia that um
when they shared about that i was like i
know what that is yeah i've done that or
i've done a parasocial obsession
uh or a relationship with someone that
doesn't know her in a relationship just
to be in something but not have to
you know do anything sexual because sex
just brings up so much for me it's so
tiring to have to it's exhausting but
it's also like i think that i've been
sued and i'm never on top still
exhausted it's so awesome i know it's
hard but i think it's like
i've been so sexual with so many
different people
and then now i'm like out of that and i
think oh i actually really like it like
i was talking to this woman
yesterday
for a long time and i realized oh
we had sex a bunch of times like i was
like oh i
i that's why she wants to talk we fucked
a bunch of times and i totally forgot
i totally forgot well that's what that's
how i know her and you don't
i'm sorry i didn't recognize you
face to face it was like where are we
she turned around and you're like
that's right i forgot but it's like
it just makes such a little impression
on me like all sex that i'm like i think
it's just
an act of trying to pretend that i'm
somehow normal by doing all of the sex i
want to ask you about um well i i want
to ask you questions from the internet
because a lot of people have a lot of
questions for you um but
do you how are you on hobbies like you
know i think people in recovery are
specifically like really good at
understanding this and it sounds odd but
i have a really hard time doing anything
and not turning it into a business
which
is a big
like it's a big like comics the fact
that we had to monetize our
conversations yeah is so fucked
and i do think a really big reason a lot
of comedians are going a little nuts
right now is that a lot of what at least
kept me sane and feeling
balanced and seen by you know equals and
people that understand what we do was
having these off the record
conversations in the hallway with fellow
comics but now when you see a comedy in
the hallway it's like
should we say let's just podcast like
that you can't just have an off the
record conversation yeah yeah anymore so
now we're monetizing our conversations
for public consumption which is great
like people love it but i find myself
not attuning to comedians and hanging
out with comedians as much not on camera
so
um i'm curious uh i am getting
because of you those plants the
carnivorous plants so great i'm obsessed
it's so great is that is and i recently
got very into plants and
it's so rewarding to fucking plant
something it's so rewarding it's it's to
me really incredible to
also uh
like play with all the different micro
climates we have in california and all
the ones that you can have in your home
it's really special and so i have a
cactus garden i have a rainforest garden
i have carnivorous plant garden i have
fruit garden vegetable garden it's so
fun why is it and i i i'm the first
person that's like oh gardening like oh
you're that guy like god we get it like
and um
but there's something i think that the
the tour i did this year was just so
wild there's something about just like
standing in the dirt and i being from
you know spending so much time in
virginia west virginia like standing in
the dirt i know there's these grounding
and there's all these like you know
i don't know the exact uh
i can't like cite a study but like the
electricity from the earth that you
because when we're only on pavement all
the time we're not getting the
electricity from the earth we're
designed to have and you know um uh i
remember my aunts that are in virginia
that i lived with for a long time they
would always say if you're sick get on a
horse and that's what native americans
used to do when you were sick because
they sort of inherently understood that
the electricity from the ground you know
uh is what kept you healthy and then
horses are more conductive so if you sit
on a horse that's what you need to do to
get better to like restore the balance
of your body
you know yeah so it's just like it's
such a basic thing but just being
barefoot in the dirt
i find myself being like
so much less sick having so much more
energy even if it's a placebo effect
placebo effect is an effect it's effect
it's an effect but it's also it keeps
you aware that you're not the only
living thing
what
[Laughter]
i beg
your partner
and it's been a pleasure interviewing
everyone i'm sorry that she's queuing on
all right
and he's lying fake news fake news
but i i'm like it's so reminded that i'm
not the only living thing like that's
why i like
basic re-parenting and a big part of you
know program is re-parenting yourself
right yeah and not uh parenting yourself
the way your parents did not that they
did anything wrong they did the best
they could with the tools they had fine
they were busy they were in a rush we
forgive others not because they deserve
forgiveness but because we deserve peace
fine but when i'm like taking care of a
plant i'm like
what if i
gave myself this much water every day
like i'm running around trying to make
sure it doesn't die and like put it in
the sun and like make sure and i'm like
if i took half as good care of myself
like it's just going like oh i can treat
myself because we're fucking plants
right so it's like why wouldn't i give
myself water why wouldn't i go in the
sun every now and then for some vitamin
d like it's just like a weird little
um
therapeutic like practice
it's so therapeutic and it's also taught
me not to be afraid of bugs i'm jumping
around i know
do you have any hot tips on how to
combat shame i literally wrote these
questions last night
and i am learning a lot about myself
well that uh i think that's really about
like everybody's really experienced it
like we've all experienced the
the frailty of being human and so
there isn't really shame or cringing
because
we've all been there so everybody
understands this shame is really the
sort of perception of self through the
eyes of somebody else that you perceive
what they were thinking you're not what
you know it's like they're just thinking
about themselves and how much they hate
themselves yeah and how much shame they
have for themselves
so i think shame is really and i mean
thinking about you and how much they
hate you they should be ashamed yeah
it's not it's not valid well that's
another um
thing about like program they say uh
other people's business
whatever other people think of you is
none of your business
and that's actually uh it's it can be a
thought terminating cliche which is
another part of you know like sometimes
in program they're like uh it works if
you work it and you're worth it yeah
those are kind of thought terminating
cliches that make you not stop thinking
and
just trust
got it which can be um to me sometimes i
have a problem with that like those
thought limiting things are stop
stopping things like a platitude that's
kind of like just just don't think about
it it's too simple okay yeah like like
in al anon it's interesting because i
think that um you know and going back
and forth between a lot of different
programs and seeing the different
approaches whereas like you know uh
sometimes in a.a it's like care more
about other people and the consequences
and
whereas aladdin is a lot of times care
less about these you know what i mean
and so alan not a big uh added or uh you
know aphorism whatever saying is it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter and that's i always
thought it was like what do you mean it
doesn't matter like everything matters
everyone's opinion of me everything i do
everything
whereas i think a lot of times in other
programs like it does matter think about
this more use your head
you know so it's interesting because as
someone like over thinking thinking
sometimes like yeah it doesn't matter it
the simple ones are sometimes what helps
me stop the loop yeah but
it's not enough for my brain it's not
enough evidence yeah it's a little bit
feels dismissive that's what yeah that's
what
bothers me sometimes about those like
sayings is that it is like it just stops
the thought yeah it's like no i would
love to stop doing that yeah no shit
yeah that's why i'm here
you know that's really interesting
because yeah i've been thinking about
shame more because you know it's i read
that book so you've been publicly shamed
oh john ronson yes yes and i guess i'm
realizing that i
i think i used to kind of get off on
other people's um you know the shot and
freudia of someone getting canceled or
their primordial
whatever tribal instinct of like
that we all go like you know we get
serotonin and endorphins from seeing
someone else get shamed because we're
learning okay don't do that like in the
sort of town square of it all like
twitter turning into the new town square
and people just sort of
stoning people when they
you know a lot of it's necessary but
whatever and watching people get
embarrassed and sort of like
rubbernecking of it and i think for some
reason
you know maybe because i'm getting back
to being emotionally sober um and doing
that work
there was someone that got sort of
allegations this past weekend and i was
just like sick to my stomach about it
and i was like okay i don't want that's
a good sign that i don't want someone
else to or i'm not getting any kind of
sick pleasure out of someone else being
publicly shamed yeah and it's just such
an interesting new like you can get
shame wherever you want these days it's
almost like it's almost like everyone's
a coke dealer like you're
sober it's like you can go online you
can find a comment you can find a
response you can google yourself like
you can
do the shame cutting to yourself
whenever you want yeah and there's no
reason to it's like just it's it's so
self-destructive and i don't yeah i i
try to be above shame i feel like i try
to be a avoidant of it because it just
doesn't do me any favors doesn't help me
at all hey bucko me again
finding everything you need is easy on
thrive market because you can filter by
90 plus values and lifestyles to find
what works for you that sentence didn't
come naturally to me but i do want you
to know in the way i would ex explain it
is that eating healthy is a nightmare
we're all dying everybody's sick you
have to pull your shit together and you
don't only eat healthy stuff but most
people don't have time to read the uh
back of every cereal box and every oat
bucket and you know no one has time to
read all the hieroglyphics in the back
of everything to make sure that there's
no red number five or bio day by as a
lime green you know so what thrive
market does is they carefully vet each
and every item so that you can trust
that if they sell it it's gonna be the
highest quality available you have to
worry about it you're not gonna get home
and get hoodwinked to be like wait a
second this is corn syrup this is made
out of
like that's so funny to me because i
feel like what we thought was healthy 30
years ago like corn syrup that sounds so
healthy
yeah what do you mean it's a vegetable
like it's so weird that's my favorite i
put it on my pancakes it's just weird to
think how unhealthy like we j i need
someone else to do the work for me
because you know what how this is who i
am i can't keep up right and i don't
want to go to 10 different places trader
joe's is like the pregame to grocery
shopping because you go to trader joe's
and then you go to the grocery store to
get what you need yes and then i gotta
go to three grocery stores i don't i
don't have time for that yeah look at me
okay do i look like i have time for that
where do you get off
grocery stores
stop by what you eat and what matters
most to you with over 5 000 food home
and beauty products finding what you
need is easy on thrive market it's what
we call
a no-brainer i came up with that myself
that's amazing join thrive market today
and get 80 000 in free groceries join
fried market today and get eighty
dollars in free groceries that's
teenagers
you said eighty thousand
join thrive market today and get eighty
dollars
oh boy join thrive market today and get
eighty dollars in free groceries that's
t h r i v e market dot com slash g f y
to get eighty dollars in free groceries
that's thrivemarket.com gfy
thrivemarket.com gfy again that will get
you eighty 80 off not 80 000.
i just said that
no one is more enthusiastic about wine
than emily the way that you store wine
is everything about it right and what
we've seen that amber heard and johnny
depp not so good at storing wine no
because it's midair had they had
a fridge from wine enthusiasts right
which is the best destination for the
wine lifestyle offering an incredible
selection
of wine accessories glassware wine
storage and more and we whitney just got
a wine fridge from wine enthusiast this
is us opening it we're very excited
you guys this is the hardest i've ever
seen emily try to get something open and
the fastest i've never
i have never seen emily do manual labor
in my life
i get a paper cut
and
guess why she's so eager beaver to get
in there
this
is is it a giant sybian with a dildo
attached no is it the brand new
real biotic sex man
that would marry her and never talk back
and say whatever lines she programmed
nope that's on back order it is a wine
fridge
give it to us farrah boy we got
something for you that is fancy yeah
look at the
mine
um wow that is that's a beaut that's a
real that is a beauty it is so beautiful
it made me feel like i was in ex machina
it's like if ex machina robot made a
wine fridge and it's like mirrored on
the outside it's very sleek and very
sensual and it fits perfectly i i think
i know where i'm going to put it but
it's like just put it right by me
no it then it'll always be empty it is
perfectly compact and it's it's saving
me so much space in other places where i
was like jamming right into random yeah
holes in my body yeah oh yeah that's
right otherwise i just had to store the
wine in my belly i was like i don't know
where to put all this wine i guess i
need to store it in my belly and to cool
it i mean damn it
to warm it up i was sitting on it visit
why would that warm it up
yeah it's like a chicken
like sits on eggs
visit wine enthusiasts.com or text the
code gfy2511 511 from now until july 4th
don't miss wine enthusiasts july 4th
wine cellar and furniture sale find big
savings on wine storage and furniture
text gfy to 511 511 to see for yourself
text gfy to 511 11 today certain
exclusions may apply you may receive up
to one additional text text fees may
apply text stop to opt out
back to the show let me ask you i know
everybody asked talks about this but i
think i maybe have a little bit of a
different point of view about
it's so funny because i'm not i'm not
trying to be shitty to anyone but you
know wherever i have been going recently
people who aren't comics they're like
god it is
must be so hard to be a comedian right
now like you are
i hear like it is
how do you do it it's like there's three
words we're not allowed to say
and all of a sudden people like how do
you do it i'm like it's pretty easy to
not say the n word like i'm not this
doesn't seem that hard for me
but
i think there's this um
i don't know i just i i'm a little bit
like
psyched about
there being some eggshells on the ground
again i'm kind of not the being hit in
the face thing i'd i'd rather not be
attacked on stage um but this whole like
three years ago nothing was taboo
sex like there was a pee tape like our
president had maybe a pee tape like
nothing it was like impossible to shock
audiences like now it's like i feel like
it's kind of nice that there's danger in
comedy again well it makes you have to
be skillful
you know and that's what i think it's
requiring of comics is to be really
skillful and nuanced and think about
what they're saying and how it'll be
perceived in the future of that joke we
never like we never thought beyond the
immediate like payoff but now we're
thinking in the long term which i think
is productive and like if you're and
it's also like i am i get excited about
the challenge to not go for the low
hanging fruit or be cheap it's like you
know or just like lean on a word to
shock someone but it's like yeah if
you're gonna do a rape joke it better be
the best rape joke you know you know
what i mean it better be
smarter than it is
you know demeaning or whatever it can't
just be shocking because it is just
shock value there's got to be a lot more
to it and then i think so that makes it
just more valuable i think it's better i
was on uh i was at the comedy store
where i was like i don't know maybe a
couple months ago and there was a
comedian and he was doing a bit about
fat chicks
and fat chicks and fat chicks and it
just wasn't doing well
no one was trying to cancel and like it
just no one was laughing it wasn't like
people were like trying to not laugh and
it was so funny and they were trying it
just wasn't funny yeah and uh
ten years ago probably was five years
ago probably people would have laughed
at it and um a woman raised her hand and
went can you stop
and it was such a like crazy moment but
it was just like this is
comedy's a democracy
like we don't get to say like fuck you
for i just see a lot of comedians being
like that's funny and like you're
fucking sensitive and you're a lib tart
it's like comedy is involuntary laughing
like i don't think anyone's holding back
a laugh and then like we don't like this
it's just like you know i think there's
a little bit of uh comedians being like
king baby about going um
you know it's free speech first
amendment it's like okay so you're
allowed to say whatever you want but
someone's not allowed to say they don't
like your comedy
you're allowed to have free speech but
the audience isn't yeah it's so funny
it's so ridiculous we're such big babies
yeah i mean but it's also like they're
just
i don't know i think the audiences are
also more sophisticated now and they
want more and because there's access to
so much comedy yeah which is great it
used to be like whoever's in town you're
going to go see them where you would go
see somebody just to just go to the club
just to laugh and not go to see a
particular artist because you like them
yeah like i think it's cool that peop
because i mean i think that i definitely
would feel like oh god the dumbest stuff
works i think it's cool now that the
smartest stuff works yeah i love that
and we get to play the top of our
intelligence it is it's really good um
okay i'm gonna a couple questions from
the internet because people are very
excited about you um what's still on
your to-do list
i want to go to
um
i want to go and look at there's a
a couple of really big carnivorous
plants like in southeast asia that i
would like to go up and hike to
so that that's kind of like be careful
yeah i mean there's ones that are like
totally um
they look like a toilet and then uh
sometimes like rodents will shit in
there and then uh
the
but they
there's like a laxative in their lid
and then um the rodents will lick the
lid and then shit in
the
flower and that's the flowers food i
want to see that plant is it called the
nepenthes yes cinnapentes with stems
reaching up to nearly five feet in
pitchers that grow to roughly a foot in
diameter it's the world's largest
carnivorous plant endemic to borno
nepenthes
borneo yeah they're important borneo i
said that wrong enormous that's wild and
that's in i'm sorry did you say peru
it's it's in southeast asia they have
them in south america they have them all
over the world i think but like mostly
they're exciting
on one of them yeah they sit it looks
like a toilet and they'll sit on it that
is wild it's so cute
yeah it's so cute that is crazy
i've never seen anything like that that
is incredible so i want to see those
plants i also want to see the big plants
that have like uh i'm growing one but
it'll take about 10 years to bloom i
think it's called the titus arum and
it's uh
it only has like one flower and a 10
year span and it smells like rotting uh
rotting flesh
it's like the stinking corpse flower oh
yeah so i have one but it's it's very is
rotting flesh smell like i hear it's
very like putrid and like
shocking um it smells like i don't know
i've i worked i used to work with
cadavers and um
at nursing school so i went to nursing
school very briefly uh when i was
starting in comedy i thought oh i'll
maybe be a nurse and um but they smelled
like formaldehyde a lot so they didn't
get like a fresh rotting corpse i never
actually smelled like rotting corpses
but i've smelled
decaying not decaying but a preserved
like in formaldehyde corpses um do you
know about mung diving
no what's that
katya
uh taught me about this on podcast last
week it's like it's like one of those
like cleveland steamer
like things where
you find a corpse that has been dead for
three or four days right
and it's gets bloated
i guess when it's not treated with
formaldehyde and you
affix your mouth onto one of the holes
and then someone else jumps on it oh so
so the fluid
explodes out and it's so um toxic it's
like there's like an ammonia and it
makes you high oh wow
[Music]
that's so caught yeah it's so
gotcha it makes it sound like it's a
very real thing right okay she's like it
has to be uh uh about four days old
that's when you know it's getting juicy
i love it and you fix your mouth
it's so ridiculous that's great okay
someone said hello from darren okay that
was really useful thank you so much i
appreciate it i know everyone wants us
to talk about recovery we did that
um oh what that mouth do someone asked
you guys can you pull it fucking
together please
favorite actor you work with
patty duke oh
she was great she told me that um
she was supposed to be she had had a
fight with sharon tate
um she was in an argument because they
were actually
um
renting
from they had gotten the house from it's
terry meltzer's house but they they had
her and john aston had like some
argument with
sharon tate about the house and they
were in a fight but then
patty duke was going to go over there
the night that they were murdered by the
man's family but then she didn't go
because she had a cold and she didn't
want to get chair and sick because
sharon was so pregnant
and um
so patty duke she she's also a great
actress but uh she was talking about how
um and i i was like oh my god we have to
do a screening of valley of the dolls
and you have to tell that story and
she's like oh nobody's gonna come to a
screening i'm like
you're so amazing but i thought that was
so
fascinating that she was like yeah i was
supposed to be there so couple more best
advice for someone in their 20s who
hates their body
well uh
you got to figure out how to love it
because this is it this is our body your
container this is what we get you know
and this is like find a way to love it
you know you have to just
do it because time goes by
real fast
and you're going to be 60 in that body
hopefully
you know if you're lucky you get to be
60 in that body so and guess what i know
this is a trait thing to say just get
older
yeah it just i don't it's time takes
time and
you know it is
maybe
you know somewhat ironic or whatever
that
ostensibly when your body is the closest
to the socially constructed idea of
beauty that's when you hate it the most
whatever who cares but it will get there
are some things that it's like the
wisdom you only get with age and you
just have to get older jealousy same
thing i was like like
fraught with jealousy and then i just
got older and it just started going away
yeah i was like if i'm jealous i just
like
my body's just telling me not to be with
you or i'm projecting because i'm doing
something shady like it's like there's
certain things that just sort of
dissipate with age like i've done a lot
of work but it's also just kind of like
i don't know the older you get you know
like after i froze my eggs i was like my
body is awesome
like that's what like i just did like a
magic trick like you start to just like
value different things so a lot of times
with stuff like that i'm like just give
it a couple years yeah just like your
self-obsession is just you know
and also do things outside like do
things that make you appreciate your
body that also helped me i said yeah i
started training with like a trainer you
remember that like to get stronger
instead of thinner
and
i uh my dog i have a very big dog who
got an injury and i had to carry he's
like 100 pounds i had to carry him into
the car to get him to the hospital in
time and i remember being like i do not
care about being skinny i do not give a
shit if my thighs touch i do not give a
shit if i have wrinkles like i need to
nurture my body and train my body so
that i can carry
an animal if they're
a hundred pound animal so important yeah
so it's like stretching and like taking
care of my body so that i'm able to
be a warrior if i need to yeah and and
changing going like i'm not
you know
making my body a fuck toy
like i'm not working out to be a fuck
toy for some weirdo who's confused about
a sexuality because if you're into my
thighs not touching you need to work it
out yeah it's weird work it out go to
the scientology center
last one how do you deal with resentment
um
i think it's really like what is just
going into like what is it that like i'm
resentful of and trying to figure out
like what's that where does that come
from and like what if i feel it really
deeply then it means it has nothing to
do with what the resentment is has to do
with old
wounds
that i'm covering up that i'm projecting
interesting
yeah resentment dude it's like
this is one of those sort of trite
things but um it always helps me to
remember resentment is like taking
poison and expecting the other person to
die it's like the other person's not
getting punished by this no i'm just
getting cancer yeah and it's like yeah
there's no benefit no one wins it's like
a crystallizing of a resentment and
forgiving the person helps me
um or apologizing to the person because
a lot of times when i resent someone
it's like i wasn't clear i wasn't i was
vague or my expectations were too high
and i'm just setting myself up to feel
like shit yeah because that's my comfort
zone yeah and they know nothing about
what's going on no i'm using them to get
my hit of resentment right they have no
idea and if they knew i was resentful
they'd be horrified yeah you know it's
just my own little masturbatory thing
okay last last thing because we asked
this to everyone um
and you're one of the people i want to
hear from the most about it is like any
um
uh red flags in people in partners when
they call women female i can't believe
you just said that
have i said that before yeah
that is i've heard you say that and i'm
like oh that's so right yeah i'm hanging
out with this female
she's female and i'm like fucking yuck
dude
yeah i hate that so much
[Music]
oh that's such a gross one it's so by
the way call
i my ex used to fight about this all the
time
he would call
people that he worked with women
like this young woman in my office like
we just hired this young woman i'm like
why don't you say woman mm-hmm look
she's like 22 and you're like but
stop i don't think we need young woman
it's a phrase at all
just say girl or woman yeah because i
also don't like it when they say this
young lady and she's like 14. you're
like well that's a girl yeah and then
they're like this young woman and she's
like 25 i'm like so if she's 30 she's a
what like what is it
you're doing math in your head on
someone's a a woman's age that you're
not fucking and it's just weird it's
weird in a professional environment it's
such a small thing but it says speaks
volumes yeah like you just don't and i
know that your dad probably said that
and you probably still say secretary and
stewardess or whatever it's fine but
like
it's a small thing that he did not
understand why it drove me so crazy but
it's it's upsetting i'm not jealous of
her i don't care about it no you don't
have to view you don't need to put young
in front of no anything
it's it's a weird it's a weird thing and
you don't need to call a teenager a
young lady to make her more mature yeah
it's weird that you get attention
because i was reading this thing about
like i'm still was trying to wrap my
head around like grooming and what's it
in like and i was like that i i i was
able to if i can't get like a working
definition of something i get
my brain gets scrambled and i was like
there's this allegation of this this
person grooming someone i was like what
does that mean exactly like
don't you just try to fuck them or flirt
isn't it just called flirting isn't it
called just being a predator and i was
like oh i i then i
it's
what i saw and what
how i'm able to explain it
is because when we say sexual harassment
all our brains go to a million different
things like we use these big umbrella
terms because we don't want to get
specific
you know and uh like sexual assault like
some people think grabbing an ass and
some people think like we don't want to
have to say
right what it is but um grooming it's
like
this guy was trying to make this young
girl feel more mature
so that she felt old enough to like it's
a way of like trying to make someone
feel like special and mature enough to
eventually be in a sexual relation so
it's like it was very like well because
you're so smart and you're so you have
such an old soul and you it's yeah that
creepy shit well it's normalizing the
abnormal
but gradually enough that you don't
notice until it's too late and making it
seem like you're the same age
when you're not yeah and and all those
you're so mature you're so precocious
you're so ahead of your time you're so
smart
and it's like convincing you're
gaslighting yourself that this is
appropriate when it's not and it's
gaslighting the other person into saying
like this is
you're so mature that you're not like
other girls yeah you're not like other
boys like you should
you're light years ahead of them you're
an old soul like that shit yeah and i
was just like i was like i got it now
because i didn't really underst i
couldn't really articulate grooming
before because i was like why would you
wait a year to fuck something like that
didn't it just didn't compute to me yeah
how fucked up that was
red flag grooming
uh
red flag is grooming
um
do i have any new ones i feel like i got
a couple new ones maybe this weekend
someone that has the um the a sticker on
their hat still
okay
got it i know that's like in style but
you're making because everyone's going
oh the sticker's not like oh you forgot
to take and then you have to go well
it's on purpose and like we're both
yeah now i have to leave
dude don't like do you know what i mean
like just don't
do that
um
i feel like i thought of some good ones
this weekend someone with um
like uh i love these women but quotes on
their email sign off from like marilyn
monroe or
audrey hepburn
which are always falsely attributed like
a you know um
what is it well-behaved women are never
remember
never make history
that was never said by any of those
people it wasn't like mayweather i mean
if anything i feel like it was maywest
yeah probably but it was like that it's
always attributed to like marilyn monroe
or somebody like that marilyn's remember
i was like bitch i was a drunk i didn't
say any shit
it's just a weird one but yeah i hate i
i don't like email sign-offs in general
yeah yeah yeah
i also don't like it because if we're
you you need to remember your own email
sign off especially when you're being an
idiot
so if you're like
per my last email i've already sent this
and then it's like treat everyone with
kindness oscar wilde and like did you
not see how you why don't you read your
own fucking quote you weirdo it's so
weird yeah like that there there's one
like um there's someone i work with and
it's um a charles bukowski quote and
he's like a producer it's like i'm like
do you not know who charles pickowski do
you know who he is like there's
literally a video of youtube of him
kicking a girl off of a couch like have
you read any of his books like it's just
a wild thing to put in an email yeah do
you have a favorite quote i don't know
if it's a quote it's just like a sort of
that buddhist idea that
uh
you know pain is inevitable but
suffering is optional
which i think is like that's sort of
kind of the way that i like to live you
know it's like we're gonna feel pain but
then you don't you have a choice of
whether you want to suffer from it or
not
wow
that's a good one yeah that's just kind
of my suffering gets me so much
attention the suffering is also oh it
gets me so many likes it's also fun to
do but it's also like
you don't have to no
this is a choice and then but also being
able to go like
oh like i can stop at any moment yeah
and it's never too late to stop i don't
have to like just because i got in this
boat and i'm going down the river i can
just like stop yeah you know
that's so in that is such a good one one
that just came to mind for me and i
don't know if i totally believe this but
i like it um for me and my like just
since the theme a little bit today i
feel like it's emotional sobriety like
the way you do anything is the way you
do everything
it's just a like for me sometimes i have
trouble like finishing something and
i'll start like five projects i'll do
five things then i won't finish them and
even if it's like brushing my teeth and
not putting the cap on the toothpaste
it's like let me just slow the fuck down
and because this is where the rubber
hits the road with my self-esteem
i never fucking finish anything i never
get anything done i'm a fucking slob i'm
a fucking mess i can never find anything
that all comes from
that five seconds of put the glass back
in the cupboard because you're gonna
instead of in some random fucking place
and then your things are a mess and then
i'm creating future chaos for myself
and like
that is like the way you do anything the
way that i punctuate an email is the
same as the way that i in a relationship
i
commute whatever like
and that's where i get in integrity
that's like where integrity comes in
like clean up after like simple stuff
like that yeah i love that um
can we talk about your tour dates real
quick yes and everything you're doing
i'm just doing shows i'm going to kansas
city tomorrow oh nice and then portland
after that oh fun and then spokane i
love that spokane i love spokane yeah
jamestown new york what's that that's
the um oh that's kelly uh kelly carlin's
uh museum oh right i've written
yeah i haven't been there yeah so i'm
going there and then amazing um dc rally
uh
lutherville timonium baltimore timonium
is like baltimore basically right yeah
for wayne louisville yeah so that's um
in october so yeah i'm going back on the
road which is great we're back we're
back so wild it's nice so surreal yeah
it's time everyone i feel like is so
excited to be
like
doing live comedy is so
electric right now it is and it's just
like we just appreciate it so much i
think so too i think yeah there's been a
i was listening to talk about this on
something i i definitely needed a
uh uh
to miss it a little bit to come back
going oh like instead of hate fucking it
i needed a little like it's so fun
excitement
like uh what is it
i was getting what is it when you start
um taking for granted something i think
i started taking it for granted and i
think people are so excited
it's a good antidote to everything on
the internet it is in person people want
jokes they understand the complex
complexities of jokes um this is where i
start stuttering this is the part of the
podcast where i start getting palsy um
it's just like so electric right now
yeah well i want to see you
um i end these super awkwardly
i love you guys thank you don't write
elephants the legend that is margaret
chow
[Music]
foreign
[Music]